عندما يأتي المريض لأول مرة إلى مكتبنا ،
فإنه يشعر بقليل من الوعي الذاتي
بشأن الطريقة التي يبدو بها أو أنهم لا يريدون أن
ينظروا إلى الناس - أعتقد دائمًا
أنني أفعل هذا فقط لأسباب تجميلية
ولكنه في الواقع استعادة
أنا طبيب عيون ، لكن بصفتي
شخصًا يناسب ويصنع عيونًا صناعية
للأشخاص أثناء الجراحة لإزالة
عينك ، يقوم الأطباء بوضع غرسة
في مخروط العضلات حتى نلائم
شكلًا محدبًا مقعرًا يجلس مثل
العدسة اللاصقة على الزرع  إنه شكل فني نقوم
بكل شيء يدويًا أولاً ، نأخذ
انطباعًا ، وهذا يعطينا
بصمة لهياكل Zack خلف لوحة الجفون
يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا ، كل شيء
يبدأ من قرص أسود وكل
شيء مرسوم فوق ذلك من
الصعب جدًا مطابقته  لون القزحية ، لا يوجد
شخصان لهما نفس اللون ، لذلك سنجلس
هناك بفرشاة رسم وسنرسم
هياكل مختلفة ، نقاط شرطات
تتراكب
مع ألوان مختلفة أو تشبع مختلف
لنعطيه التأثير ثلاثي الأبعاد الذي
نراه في عيون الناس الطبيعية ، جزء
مما يجعله يبدو طبيعيًا هو أن يكون
لديك بريق في عينك ، نقوم بذلك من خلال
تلميع دقيق وضبط
منحنيات العين الاصطناعية وهو الجزء
الأكثر  الإعجاب بصناعة الطرف الاصطناعي
هو عندما انتهيت منه وألقيت نظرة
عليه وأرى الوهم الذي
خلقته للتو عندما يفقد شخص ما عينه
أحيانًا يشعر وكأنه فقد
جزءًا من كيانه الذاتي ، فنحن نجعله
يشعر بالراحة مرة أخرى  وواثق من أنه
سيواجهك العالم